c'est grâce à la tempête que le tambour
n'a aucun résonne comme le tonnerre le
tonnerre engendre les éclairs il est
clair en gendre de feu épars tour du
tambour
dusty cropper natural rapoport
j'imaginais plus grands
alors tu veux devenir un canada au nom
lille mon petit les camping-cars n'aime
pas les bonnes vous qu'ils préfèrent
venir faire la fête avec moi est-ce que
c'est clair la réponse est oui oui bah
oui on devrait jamais trop dérangé de
sauter danser
on espace aérien
désolé tope là à meego mais sucre d'orge
si je devrais pas de sauter d'un v10 est
parce que tu es de la bourde qui est en
jeu mais le train d'atterrissage route
des bisous avec l'héroïne style je suis
dit peur c'est comme ça que tout le
monde appelle des mineurs aux
madmoizelles admise elle dit petit
d'accord exactement
winchester à toi jouer tipper fait le
plein et vise la bande uhf d'un certain
monsieur métais ce team pas vraiment
noté tout ce que je dis alors il écrit
ça aussi et ça oui et ça oui oh c'est
pas mon jour
sa roue
mais envoie droit vers le front accroche
toi
moi un peu de la faune du parc si tu
viens faire la fête ce soir tu verras
plein de bêtes sauvages
tu te crois pas mais des listes génial
c'est comme ça que j'aime le telecom
carnet et pisé par l'eau